le président de l'UDI le nouveau
président de l'UD Jean-Christophe
Lagarde et l'invité de Preuves par 3
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous pour
ce rendez-vous donc de Public Sénat avec
l'Agence France Presse Deborah Claude
qui suit attentivement le centre on le
sait le centre courtisé pour des
primaires ouvertes à droite sera avec
nous émission réalisée également en
partenariat avec Dailymotion et Michael
zames cette semaine de Public Sénat sera
avec nous à la fin des missions pour des
questions destinée à mieux vous
connaître Jean-Christophe Lagarde vous
êtes également député maire de Drancy en
Seine-Saint-Denis d'abord l'aveu par
Emmanuel Macron que le pacte de
responsabilité qui traduit en le sait le
cap économique du gouvernement pour une
plus grande compétitivité des
entreprises donc l'aveu que ce pacte
était un échec il en a plus de la
responsabilité au patron mais est-ce que
vous comprenez que le ministre de
l'Économie parle dès aujourd'hui d'un
échec d'abord c'est une curiosité le
ministre du Travail disait que le
gouvernement était en échec sur le
travail maintenant le ministre de
l'Économie dit qu'il est en échec sur
l'économie
c'est une curiosité deuxièmement parce
que le pack de responsabilité en réalité
il est toujours pas en œuvre enfin voilà
à propos qui a été tenu par François
Hollande de mémoire le 31 décembre 2013
qui commence seulement à entrer en
application c'est à dire en réalité la
baisse des charges des entreprises 40
milliards d'euros
sur plusieurs années mais attendez 40
milliards de dégrèvement ou de baisse
des charges pour les entreprises à terme
mais aujourd'hui on est même pas arrivé
au niveau des augmentations d'impôts
qu'ils ont imposées aux entreprises au
cours des années 2012-2013 en 2014 on
n'est pas encore revenus en dessous
alors qu'elles effets en attente t-il
quels effets on attendit deuxièmement
plutôt que de faire nous l'avions dit
nous à l'UDI plutôt que de faire une
usine à gaz le cice il fallait comme
nous le proposions transférer
massivement les charges sociales sur la
taxe sur la consommation sur la TVA
d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'il a fait pour
pouvoir baisser les charges des
entreprises il a augmenté la TVA des
Français la TVA qui passait à 20% qui a
augmenté de cet ennemi à 10% pour l'auto
intermédiaire c'est 43% d'augmentation
j'aimerais voir les économies parce que
comme membres de la commission des
finances à l'Assemblée nationale je les
attends encore en tout cas pour ce qui
concerne les comptes de l'État ils en
ont fait sur les opérateurs de l'État
sur les collectivités locales plantant
là l'activité des du bâtiment et des
travaux publics mais pour revenir quand
on augmente les impôts des entreprises
de 20 milliards qu'au jour d'aujourd'hui
on a amorcé une baisse de 10 milliards
c'est toujours plus dix ça peut pas
avoir quand même cette déclaration
politique de du ministre de l'économie
qui qui est anticipe l'échec en quelque
sorte puisque vous nous rappelez
effectivement que le pacte de
responsabilité n'est pas véritablement
entrer en application je crois que le
ministre de l'Économie et son premier
ministre ils font de la politique là ils
essaient de rassurer leur aile gauche
parce que ça tangue un peu trop alors il
leur dit vous voyez finalement on a fait
des grandes déclarations d'amour aux
entreprises mais on est capable aussi de
dire que c'est des vilains patrons
une fois de plus comme depuis le début
du mandat de François Hollande on tire à
U et à dia on va dans le Zig et danzaï
pendant ce temps-là la France fait du
surplace les Français perdent leur
emploi perdent leur pouvoir d'achat nos
entreprises continuent à fermer l'an
dernier c'est 63000 entreprises qui
ferment et on attend encore un président
de la République qui grosso modo
contemple la situation
au lieu de donner un vrai entre
guillemets choc économique un vrai big
bang pour qu'on puisse redémarrer mais
est-ce que néanmoins Emmanuel Macron est
le premier ministre en raison de
polémiquer avec le patronat qui traîne
un peu quand même c'est vrai il est par
exemple uniquement deux accords de
branches aujourd'hui dans le cadre de ce
pacte de responsabilité or le patronat
est attendu sur les contreparties mais
moi je ne crois pas l'histoire des
contreparties c'est une fumée historique
pour calmer des députés et des
parlementaires socialistes pardon
l'emploi c'est une conséquence c'est pas
un préalable c'est-à-dire que c'est
parce qu'une entreprise va pouvoir
produire moins cher vendre mieux ces
produits qu'elle a besoin de salariés
pour pouvoir ensuite euh comment
dirais-je produire toujours et continuer
à vendre c'est pas on leur dit on vous
baisse les charges et vous allez
embaucher et s'il fallait le faire votre
solution c'est un chèque en blanc alors
non s'il fallait le faire il fallait le
faire bien plus intelligemment ce que
nous avions proposé je vous prends un
exemple hier dans la rue se trouvait des
petits patrons la CGPME c'est pas les
habitués les manifestations c'est des
gens qui travaillent 12-14 15 heures par
jour qui sont allés dans la rue pour
dire ça suffit ces petits patrons quand
ils ont décidé de créer les emplois
d'avenir que nous il y a mon voter nous
avions demandé qu'il puisse bénéficier
des emplois d'avenir pourquoi les
emplois d'avenir qui sont payés à 75%
par l'État ne bénéficient qu'aux
collectivités locales et aux
associations vous croyez pas qu'un
commerçant et un artisan ça lui
permettrait d'avoir un salarié qu'il
forme pendant trois ans qu'il garderait
parce qu'il a pu développer son activité
et ça lui donnerait de la compétitivité
plutôt que de mépriser comme on a
entendu madame Touraine ou monsieur
Valls des gens qui travaillent 14 à 15
heures par jour en prenant tous les
risque dans leur vie et hier
les dirigeants patronaux non non pardon
il a dit responsabilités
c'est l'exagération et la caricature et
bien l'exagération et la caricature
c'est que Monsieur Valls ou madame
Touraine de façon très
méprisante puisse dire ça à celles et
ceux qui créent des emplois dans notre
pays parce que ce sont eux qui créent
des emplois c'est pas l'état et puis
pardon de vous dire que j'ai jamais
entendu un ministre socialiste et encore
moins un premier ministre dire ça quand
on a des grèves à répétition à
l'initiative de la CGT pour vous il n'y
a pas de problème gataz par exemple
comme le dit le porte-parole du
gouvernement Stéphane Le Foll moi je
pense que le problème il vient du
gouvernement c'est quand même le
gouvernement qui impulse une politique
économique et vous croyez que c'est
Monsieur Gattaz qui décide pour les
autres patrons de recruter les patrons
ils recrutent quand ils ont besoin de
salariés parce qu'ils peuvent vendre
leurs produits sinon tout simplement ils
peuvent pas recruter puisqu'ils vendent
rien alors vous nous dites que Emmanuel
Macron est premier ministre prendre la
politique quand il polémique ainsi quand
ils disent de la politique politicienne
quand il poursuivent leurs bras de fer
avec le patronat est-ce que
Jean-Christophe Cambadélis le patron du
ça se fait de la politique également
politicienne quand il critique la loi
fourre-tout du ministre de l'économie
quand il critique une loi en demandant
qu'elle ne touche pas autant de travail
qu'elle ne touche pas au seuils sociaux
et qu'elle n'aille pas aussi loin dans
la libération des dimanches
ouvertes par les magasins mais écoutez
de la part du premier secrétaire du
Parti socialiste qu'elle réquisitoire
contre une contre une loi d'un
gouvernement socialiste finalement avec
François Hollande et ses amis il n'y a
pas besoin d'opposition ils sont déjà
tellement d'opposition avec ce qu'ils
font eux-mêmes
moi je suis frappé de voir que en
réalité ce que demande monsieur
Cambadélis c'est vous faites une loi ne
mettez rien dedans ne touchez pas aux 35
heures ne touchez pas au seuil sociaux
même si monsieur remsamen a reconnu que
ça posait problème et c'est un vrai
problème auquel un gouvernement
courageux devrait s'attaquer pour
libérer les énergies dans notre pays et
puis ne touchez pas non plus au travail
du dimanche bref nous touchez à rien
très franchement si c'est pour faire une
loi et ne touchez à rien on a même pas
besoin de gouvernement man la raison que
on le comprend affronte des vents
contraires dans son camp on se souvient
de sa volonté de transformer le PS en
maison ouverte au centre Jean-Christophe
Lagarde est-ce qu'une c'est une qui
pourrait vous séduire et à quelles
conditions c'était une phase curieuse du
discours qui décide aussi devient aussi
changeant son patron de président
il a dit non pas ouvert au centre je
souhaiterais une maison commune la
caractéristique et la bizarrerie c'est
qu'il est le seul à habiter dedans parce
que ses amis socialistes déjà ne veulent
pas y être et d'ailleurs vous venez de
lier les deux sujets Jean-Christophe
Cambadélis critique la loi Macron
monsieur Macron se met à critiquer le
patronat alors que le premier ministre
il y a trois mois déclaré son amour pour
les chefs d'entreprise il y a là
manifestement des jeux et des tensions
qui existent entre eux et donc
elle est vide il est le seul habitant
deuxième chose oui excusez-moi quel
autre société s'y est rendu ou a répondu
favorablement à cette offre deuxième
chose
demain un grand nombre de députés autour
de lui pour montrer quand même
je suis pas persuadé qu'il les
réunissent pour leur dire bonne nouvelle
embrassons-nous Folleville désormais on
va saluer au centre d'autre part ça ne
nous intéresse pas nous ne sommes pas la
variable d'ajustement d'un gouvernement
perdition mais en plus il a fait ça
quand même la semaine ou il critiquait
l'Union européenne et Bruxelles parce
que il y a des règles à respecter et
qu'elles sont des règles acceptées par
la France il prenait l'Europe pour bouc
émissaire pour nous amener dans une
maison commune pardon et de la même
façon la semaine où il remettait en
cause un consensus national qui a 70 ans
d'âge et qui vient d'être définitivement
enterrés hier par un vote du Parlement
c'est-à-dire l'universalité des
allocations familiales deux désaccords
majeurs que nous pouvons avoir l'Europe
n'est pas le bouquet du cerf des
insuffisances françaises parce que en
réalité ce sont les insuffisances
françaises qui posent problème et pas
l'Union européenne vous croyez que c'est
l'Union européenne n'était pas là que si
les règles de l'Union n'étaient pas là
on pourrait continuer à dépenser plus
d'argent que ce qu'on crée vous croyez
qu'on trouverait des gens pour prêter
vous pensez que quand la Grèce a connu
une difficulté c'est de la faute de
Bruxelles ou c'est de la faute en
l'occurrence et de la Grèce et des
dépenses excessives parce que même s'il
y avait pas eu Bruxelles il y aurait
plus de banqueroute parce que quand la
stigmatisation de l'Europe aujourd'hui
elle vient pas tellement de du Premier
ministre de Manuel Valls vous avez
entendu Nicolas Sarkozy hein est-ce
qu'il fait un retour trop à droite selon
vous en mettant en avant les questions
de l'immigration la relation de la loi
Taubira et justement les compétences
européennes puisqu'il veut les réduire
de moitié j'y viens mais pardon si et ce
mois ça va consterner pendant la
campagne européenne et dans cette
séquence là que le gouvernement et le
Parti socialiste finissent par prendre
l'Europe comme bouc émissaire quand
monsieur sapin arrive en disant l'Europe
n'a rien à nous dicter bien sûr que non
le victorien c'est des accords que la
France a accepté l'Europe n'a rien à
diviser c'est ici que nous décidons etc
pour finalement d'ailleurs être obligé
d'augmenter les impôts de 4 milliards
pour essayer de trouver un accord quand
à Nicolas Sarkozy bien sûr nous avons un
désaccord avec Nicolas Sarkozy sur la
construction européenne nous sommes
fédéralistes nous voulons un
gouvernement économique de la zone de la
zone euro nous pensons que c'est le seul
moyen contrairement à ce que raconte le
tandem Mélenchon de Le Pen les
déclinistes ceux qui veulent qu'on
s'enferme derrière des frontières
illusoires c'est la seule façon en nous
fédérant de reconquérir nos
souverainetés en ayant
le disent pas comme vous nous assumons
parce qu'il faut dire la vérité aux
Français
une stratégie globalement
laissez-moi terminer sur l'Europe
puisque c'est une vraie différence une
stratégie monétaire commune une
stratégie industrielle commerciale et
énergétique commune parce que c'est la
seule solution pour que nous puissions
avoir notre indépendance face aux
États-Unis à l'Inde à la Chine qui sinon
nous dicte les conditions en fonction de
leurs intérêts quant à nickel assarkozy
moi j'avoue que j'ai
regretté que dans la campagne interne on
verra ce qu'il en sera par la suite
qui est une espèce de dérive progressive
à droite ou de reprise de la campagne
2012 je ne pense pas combattre le Front
national combatte l'extrême droite en
courant derrière elle je pense que pour
battre l'extrême droite il faut la
combattre et il faut aller y par idée
démontrer
l'absurdité des propos qui sont tenus
j'ai eu récemment un débat avec une
représentante de l'extrême droite elle
disait grosso modo il faut pas l'aide
médicale d'État c'est-à-dire on soigne
pas les gens qui ont pas de papier et
quand quelqu'un arrive en France avec le
virus Ebola qu'est-ce qu'on fait on
soigne pas parce qu'il a pas de papier
de plus en plus repris
donc je condamne le fait de suivre
l'extrême droite sur ce genre de propos
on met la population en danger quand
quelqu'un a la tuberculose on ne soigne
pas parce qu'il a pas de papier donc on
risque la diffusion de la tuberculose en
plus évidemment du risque de décès de la
personne ça n'est pas comment dirais la
différence pour moi entre la droite et
l'extrême droite ne peut pas être une
question de degré c'est une question de
nature et je veux que nous puissions
combattre l'extrême droite en expliquant
pourquoi il menthe aux Français il
manteaux français quand ils disent qu'on
va fermer les frontières de quel produit
allons-nous vous passer votre ordinateur
il est produit en France on fait comment
pour l'avoir demain l'énergie les
matières premières et quand bien même on
surtaxerait ces produits ça aurait deux
conséquences la première c'est que ça
serait plus cher pour chaque Français
puisqu'on est à l'extrême droite ou à
l'UMP toujours là
alors justement ce n'est pas le cas
Nicolas Sarkozy mais une partie de l'UMP
est aussi en train de parler de fermer
les frontières est-ce que Bruno Le Maire
aurait été un meilleur président de
l'UMP pour vous et selon vous le MP5
comme elle le souhaite et se choisissait
responsable je n'accepterai pas que du
MP se mêle des affaires de Ludi je vais
pas m'en mêler maintenant vous me
demandez à commentaire sur la ligne
politique la fermeture des frontières ça
aurait deux conséquences ou la
surtaxation ça aurait deux conséquences
la première ça rendrait des produits
plus chers pour notre pays la seconde
conséquence c'est qu'évidemment les
produits français subiraient des mesures
en rétorsion et donc on sera plus en
difficulté encore pour exporter une
question sur le drame Rémi Fraisse au
barrage de Sivens la commission
d'enquête a conclu qu'il n'y avait pas
eu de fautes de des gendarmes est-ce que
vous pensez que moi je décision
j'attends l'issue du ciel
polémique j'attends donc l'issue de
l'enquête judiciaire il y a trois choses
que je n'ai pas aimé dans cette affaire
la première c'est qu'on est enquête de
l'inspection générale de la gendarmerie
judiciaire parce que je pense que il y a
une enquête judiciaire en cours et que
la justice étant indépendante ce qui
n'est pas le cas de l'inspection
générale de la gendarmerie on n'aura
plus entre guillemets la clarté des
choses je n'aime pas commenter des
choses quand elles sont pas faites il y
a trois choses de gênant dans cette
affaire la première c'est que
immédiatement les forces de police ont
été mises en accusation je ne vois pas
de quel droit pourquoi est-ce qu'elle
serait tout de suite stigmatisée alors
qu'on ne sait rien et d'ailleurs avec
des commentaires je pense à Madame
Duflot de gens qui n'étaient pas sur
place et qui ne savaient rien de ce qui
s'est passé la deuxième chose
c'est que le ministre de l'intérieur a
été responsable de mon point de vue
lorsqu'il a interdit
l'utilisation des grenades offensives en
attendant de savoir et la troisième
chose quand même c'est que le fond du
problème c'est pas le barrage de
cervelle c'est qu'il y a eu tout un
processus légal démocratique de décision
des élus qui rendent des comptes à la
population qui majoritairement
souhaitait ce projet et que c'est par la
violence que ce projet a été arrêté il y
aurait pas dû y avoir un mort dans cette
affaire et c'est l'objet de l'enquête
judiciaire et de l'emploi des forces de
l'ordre mais il y aurait pas dû y avoir
violence de la part de ceux qui
manifestaient parce que sinon ça veut
dire que on a beau dans une démocratie
avoir la majorité exercer tous les
recours possibles et imaginables il
suffit de casser et de jeter les
cocktails Molotov pour arriver à la
table de la ministre de l'Environnement
c'est quand même choquant allez on va
évoquer maintenant
le centre la formation l'UDA comment
vous allez la diriger dans quelle
perspective avec cette idée de primaire
ouverte au centre évoquée à l'UMP vous
avez déjà eu un mois à l'instant sur
Nicolas Sarkozy vous allez répondre à
Deborah Claude de l'AFP dans un instant
voyons d'abord comment vous avez donc
l'intention de montrer vos muscles
Jean-Christophe Lagarde avec Sandra
circa
quand il évoque un rassemblement de la
droite et du centre Alain Juppé se fait
huer
voilà qui ont dit long la fracture
idéologique au sein du parti ne date pas
d'hier et elle aura son importance pour
2017 pas question pour les centristes de
participer à une primaire limitée à
l'UMP
udi on souhaiterait une primaire
totalement ouverte à tous les
sympathisants organisés par une instance
totalement neutre pas des primaires de
l'UMP mais où tous les candidats de
droite qui s'appellent François Bayrou
ou Nicolas Sarkozy participent dès lors
que François Béraud a dit que lui ne se
sentirait pas lié par les résultats de
cette primaire malheureusement elle est
un peu morte avant même d'avoir été
étudiée le centre droit demeure la liée
naturelle de l'UMP mais à écouter l'été
nord de l'UDI le centrisme mousse est
fini une fin de non-recevoir à Nicolas
Sarkozy qui voulait un centre avec lui
matin midi et soir le centre se dit
désormais indépendant et veut compter
aux prochaines élections locales une
liste centriste en Île-de-France n'est
pas exclue aussi souvent
quand il y avait deux bons candidats en
choisissait systématiquement le candidat
de l'UMP je crois qu'il y a un certain
nombre de candidats udiés qui seront en
mesure de porter les valeurs de l'UDI et
de tirer les listes dans les régions
concernées on a envie maintenant de
montrer un peu les muscles et de montrer
que on peut exister aussi par nous-mêmes
à droite cette émancipation des
centristes ne réjouit pas tout le monde
surtout ce pour qui l'avenir de l'UMP
passe par une alliance solide avec le
centre au point de vouloir un candidat
unique en 2017 certains veulent croire
que Nicolas Sarkozy saura convaincre
Nicolas Sarkozy sera vigilant sur ce
point il connaît les humanistes il
connaît la culture centriste d'une
partie de l'UMP il connaît tout cela
c'est pas grave c'est pas un débutant
donc laissant les choses se faire je
pense que ça consultation va l'aider
dans sa décision pour l'instant aucun
responsable centriste ne
figure mais une chose est sûre le coup
de bar à droite du nouveau président de
l'UMP libère un espace sur l'échiquier
politique que les centristes comptent
bien s'approprier
notre concert de l'AFP bonsoir Déborah
des des questions s'imposent pour
la clarification sur la primaire sur
qu'on comprenne bien ce qui se passe la
primaire vous avez dit c'est si François
Bayrou ne vient pas ça sert à rien même
quand vous avez dit pendant votre
campagne interne ils font un candidat en
2017 un candidat centriste et vous avez
dit également 3e paramètre on se
décidera au premier semestre 2016 donc
vous allez tenir jusqu'en 2016 vous
allez pas participer à une primaire
qu'est-ce qui va se passer à l'UDA
c'est un peu contradictoire moi ce que
j'ai compris
première chose j'ai expliqué et c'est un
engagement même qui a été adopté par le
Congrès nous choisirons notre stratégie
et notre candidat au premier semestre
2016 pardon de vous dire que tout le
monde
débat des primaires et de l'élection
présidentielle de 2017 je ne suis pas
sûr que ce soit la priorité des Français
et pour les partis politiques la
priorité la raison pour laquelle je
viens d'écrire à Nicolas Sarkozy c'est
que dans quatre mois il y a des
élections départementales dans 12 mois
il y a des élections régionales celle-là
elles sont urgentes et pour nous
importante pour deux raisons d'abord
parce que ça
pour parler de ça dès qu'il aurait
constitué son équipe mais il y a deux
raisons la première c'est qu'évidemment
je souhaite le maximum de basculement
entre la gauche et le centre et la
droite dans ces départements et ses
régions mais parce que deuxièmement nous
pensons que c'est à la base qu'on va
pouvoir faire redémarrer le pays il est
bloqué au sommet de l'État on le voyait
dans la première partie de l'émission
avec ses X et zags permanents mais c'est
donc dans les territoires qu'on peut
retrouver de la ressource
donc première chose oui mais vous savez
moi je suis quelqu'un d'assez
pragmatique et organisé dans un premier
temps il y a des élections dans 4 mois
et ensuite il y a des élections dans 12
mois dans un second temps il y a le
débat sur la présidentielle donc c'est
une fois passé en décembre 2015 les
élections régionales que nous
trancherons sur la stratégie et sur le
candidat ou la candidate celui ou celle
qui sera le mieux placé pour porter nos
valeurs humanistes et fédéralistes nos
solutions devant les Français si
François Bayrou n'y va pas
et par ailleurs vous me demandez dans le
sujet et par ailleurs vous me demandez
de commenter aujourd'hui une situation
politique quant à la primaire j'observe
simplement qu'une primaire ça sert à
quoi ça sert à n'avoir qu'un seul
candidat de la droite républicaine et du
centre au deuxième tour de l'opposition
républicaine au premier tour pardon au
premier ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que si
la primaire si la primaire a du sens
il faut que tout le monde y soit ce que
disait Chantal Jouanno et que je partage
si d'aucun dit ah bah faites la primaire
mais moi je m'en extrait et je fais ce
que je veux en l'occurrence je crois
comprendre je suis pas sûr que ce soit
une décision mais je crois comprendre
que ce sont les propos de François
Bayrou à la primaire n'a plus de sens
quel est faire dans une primaire
pourquoi pour sélectionner entre deux
candidatsump on n'a pas construit l'UDI
pour sélectionner entre des candidatsump
mais pour porter notre projet humaniste
et fédéraliste montrer aux Français
combien nous avons besoin de politique
de long terme parce que retrousser ses
manches c'est nécessaire mais faut que
ça ait un but c'est à dire alléger le
fardeau que nous sommes en train de
charger et de surcharger sur nos enfants
que ce soit la dette que ce soit les
traps à chômage que ce soit l'éducation
nationale qui n'est plus un ascenseur
social ça c'est notre job et on verra la
meilleure façon de faire moi je pense
que nous avons vocation après 33 ans où
nous n'avons pas gouverné la France ou
le PS et l'UMP ont gouverné
successivement et alternativement pour
arriver à 5 millions de chômeurs pour
arriver à 2000 milliards de dettes pour
arriver à une école en vrac à une
compétitivité en berne excusez-moi je
pense que nous avons autre chose à
proposer aux Français nous ne voulons
pas laisser les Français
coincés d'une certaine façon entre deux
forces politiques qui ont déjà échoué
qui ne semblent pas parvenir à se
renouveler et sinon les démagogues les
populistes et les extrémistes c'est pour
ça qu'on a créé l'UDI et c'est ça que la
question des alliances elle va quand
même se poser le centre il est dans le
débat Alain Juppé se fait siffler à
Bordeaux donc la question inévitablement
vous sera quand même posée donc j'en
risque une dernière sur la primaire et
puis après on parlera d'autres choses
sur l'organisation c'est comme Chantal
Jouanno vous estimez elle doit être
organisée de manière indépendante cette
primaire
se pose je me pose cette question moi je
me considère pas aujourd'hui je répète
donc je vais pas aller dans les détails
de l'organisation de quelqu'un dont de
quelque chose dont je ne considère pas
qui se pose parler des alliances très
bien mais moi j'ai jamais dit qu'il y
aurait pas d'alliance je ne confonds pas
notre indépendance qui est absolument
totale et l'isolement ceux qui ont
essayé ont eu des problèmes comme disait
un sketch humoristique l'isolement
politique ça veut dire ne pas gouverner
ça veut dire ne pas mettre en
application ses idées le Parti
socialiste le Parti socialiste
le Parti socialiste les écologistes les
communistes les radicaux de gauche sont
clairement indépendants les uns des
autres et pour autant il faut une
coalition pour gouverner sauf que moi je
dis et c'est ça le centre book qui est
fini la coalition ça n'est pas la
soumission l'alliance sa vie ça veut
dire aussi la concurrence et notre
ambition collective c'est de diriger la
prochaine alliance parce que nous aurons
convaincu je l'espère les Français qu'il
y a des solutions de sortie que notre
pays n'est pas foutu qu'il a des
ressources mais qu'il faut simplement
changer de vision politique avoir des
visions de long terme qui stabilisent la
fiscalité qui stabilise les objectifs et
les façons dont on gère l'éducation
nationale qui fasse en sorte que le code
du travail ne fasse pas 2 kilos et demi
et pour autant permettre aux salariés à
François
e
évidemment qu'on a des points communs
avec François Bayron on peut l'avoir
rencontré on peut avoir des désaccords
sur la stratégie on en a eu par le passé
je n'ai pas voté François Hollande je ne
souhaitais pas son élection parce que je
pensais qu'on vivrait la catastrophe que
nous vivons aujourd'hui mais je peux
même vous prendre
je vais même vous prendre une deuxième
idée qui était cher à François Bayrou et
à nous puisque nous étions à ce
moment-là ensemble les emplois France
c'est-à-dire deux emplois qui permettent
à des entreprises de pas payer de charge
c'est une bonne solution plus simple
plus rapide pour l'emploi et pour la
compétitivité des entreprises ça
coûterait sans doute moins cher que
l'usine à gaz du cice dans le ministre
de l'Économie constate quelques semaines
après être entré en fonction que c'est
déjà un échec à ses yeux
alors passons maintenant concrètement au
travail de l'UDI vous dites il faut
aussi des nouvelles têtes à l'UDI vous
êtes en train de faire l'organigramme je
crois on n'a pas encore l'équipe n'est
pas encore sortie du chapeau mais on va
pas tarder monter très bien c'est un
scoop alors qui aura dans cette équipe
de dans le renouveau de l'UDI Chantal
Jouano qu'on a vu là Yves Diego qui qui
seront les nouvelles têtes de l'udio
alors que je dis ça ne va pas tarder je
comprends que ce soit votre métier mais
moi je veux faire les choses
sérieusement en ayant l'équipe ce que je
veux dire simplement c'est que la
politique française à mes yeux a besoin
de nouvelles idées de nos logiciels et
aussi de nouvelles équipes et de
nouveaux visages et je vais m'attacher
tant dans la construction de l'équipe
nationale que dans les élections
départementales régionales à ce qu'on
puisse faire émerger des idées nouvelles
des talents nouveaux est-ce que Hervé
Morin il a pris part active à ces
discussions il y a une campagne qui a
été difficile entre vous deux
il s'est estimé le vainqueur moral de
cette élection vous avez dit après on va
discuter il avait mis quelques
conditions vous vous parlez avec Hervé
Morin comment ça se passe nous avons
discuté je présenterai pas les choses
comme ça il y a pas de conditions il y a
simplement le fait que une fois que
l'élection est passée nonobstant les
premiers jours qui sont difficiles pour
les uns et pour les autres c'est bien
naturel la page est tournée maintenant
la question elle se pose pas au sein de
l'UDI elle se pose vis-à-vis de nos
partenaires et en même temps de nos
concurrents de l'UMP et du MoDem pour
que nous puissions
occuper l'espace politique que nous
n'aurions jamais dû abandonner et nous
ne l'avions abandonné que parce que nous
étions divisés vous pensez bien qu'il
élu président du dei je vais veiller
très précieusement à ce que nous ne
divisions pas et à ce que nous ne
perdions pas le moindre talent je disais
qu'il y a des élections régionales l'an
prochain dans ces élections régionales
je pense qu'Hervé Morin est le meilleur
candidat pour la région Normandie vous
savez qu'en 2004 il y a 10 ans il y a 10
ans Hervé Morin c'était le seul qui
militait et il avait porté une liste
pour la réunion des deux régions c'est
normal que celui qui a eu entre
guillemets qui a anticipé soit peut-être
le meilleur porteur de ça mais
en Île-de-France je ne peux pas tout
faire à la fois
occuper de votre cas personnel c'est
bien de s'occuper de son ancien rival
interne mais c'est bien de s'occuper
aussi de sa famille politique c'est bien
le rôle d'un président de parti et donc
pas que de soi mais
je voulais prendre une par une très
rapide de France
il y aura qui sera peut-être candidat
pour moi
il y a il y a la région Île-de-France
nous aurons une liste udaï dans la
région Île-de-France dans votre portage
il était dit probablement les élus de la
région Île-de-France souhaitent et je
pense que c'est plus intelligent et que
c'est meilleur façon entre guillemets
d'aller gagner cette région qui est la
première région de France et qui aurait
bien besoin d'être
sensible pour être à la tête de liste
avant d'être président donc maintenant
vous avez beaucoup de choses à faire
sentira malgré moi
les couloir ni la tête
ni la tête ni le caractère de quelqu'un
qu'on va obliger entre guillemets mais
il y a des gens intéressés il y a des
gens qui souhaitent être candidats
forcément
pourrait l'envisager d'autres pourraient
en avoir envie on choisira ça c'est une
grande revendication mais
bon écoutez on voit déjà deux qui ce qui
aspirent à être candidate non et puis il
y a d'autres régions François des en
Bourgogne Franche-Comté Philippe Vigier
dans la région Centre Yannick Favennec
dans les Pays de Loire donc vous voyez
on ne manque pas ni de talent ni
d'ambition je veux pouvoir en discuter
avec les responsables de l'UMP et donc
Nicolas Sarkozy nouveau président du NP
pour que on regarde là où nous sommes
d'accord là où nous ne sommes pas si
nous sommes d'accord tant mieux et quand
tu auras des désaccords chacun des
assumera donc c'est ça le programme de
travail de dont plusieurs ont dit et
Jean-Louis Borloo a lancé l'UDI il a
fait un très un très beau jouet mais une
fois qu'il l'a lancé on n'avait pas
tellement travaillé c'est un peu ce que
plusieurs d'entre vous avais dit là se
mettre au travail c'est préparer ses
élections
parce qu'elles arrivent et qu'on va
quand même pas ne pas les préparer
évidemment puis c'est une deuxième chose
structurer le parti politique mais
surtout travailler pour décliner et
montrer aux Français en quoi les idées
humanistes dont je parle sont
effectivement une solution à la crise
aujourd'hui en réalité il y a trois
forces politiques il y a l'égalitarisme
qui est identifié à la gauche c'est à
dire grosso modo quel que soit les
efforts que vous faites vous aurez le
même résultat c'est une injustice vous
avez un individualisme c'est plutôt les
politiques choisis par la droite et ça a
l'air de s'accentuer c'est-à-dire
chercher à donner satisfaction à chaque
individu à chaque personne parfois à
chaque groupe en fonction de son désir
de son besoin de son fantasme sans
jamais penser et sans jamais expliquer
qui a besoin de temps qui a besoin
d'efforts et sans jamais regarder les
conséquences sur les autres ou sur
l'environnement et puis il y a
l'humanisme ce que nous portons qui est
de dire que le rôle d'une génération
c'est de préparer en l'occurrence la les
conditions de vie de la suivante c'est
ce que nous ne faisons plus quand
aujourd'hui un rôle de lutte contre les
idées du Front national c'est un axe que
vous aviez pris pendant la campagne des
européennes très fort nous le
poursuivrons je disais tout à l'heure
que pour battre l'extrême droite il faut
la combattre parce que en réalité c'est
pas dans les urnes que vous gagnez les
élections c'est dans les esprits montrer
que la fermeture de la France est une
catastrophe ou une illusion dangereuse
montrer que
hier soir j'ai appris sur un plateau de
télévision par la petite fille de Madame
de Monsieur Le Pen que finalement le
Front National qui écrit dans ces
traques qui veut inverser les flux
migratoires ne le fait plus pourquoi
parce que c'est juste pas possible vous
inversez quoi ça veut dire inversez ça
veut dire faire partir des gens qui sont
déjà ici et les renvoyer chez eux il
faut que le pays d'accueil soit d'accord
de ces gens là ils sont là ils occupent
des emplois que personne de vous occuper
dans notre pays et trois vous allez
jusqu'à quand depuis 5 ans depuis 10 ans
depuis 15 ans je vous rappelle qu'avant
le Front national il proposait qu'on
dénaturalise c'est-à-dire qu'on retire
la nationalité aux gens qui étaient
arrivés après 1974 voilà il faut montrer
point par point que cette absurde que le
programme économique est une catastrophe
si vous me laissez un dernier exemple
pour un fédéraliste la sortie de l'euro
est-ce que les Français comprennent que
la sortie de l'euro ça veut dire
immédiatement qu'on retourne au franc
que le franc va valoir 30% de moins avec
la traduction concrète c'est que quand
vous aurez 1000 francs dans la poche ça
en vaudra 800 700 d'aujourd'hui c'est ça
la réalité appauvrir la France et
d'ailleurs une caractéristique de
Mélenchon de peps je les appelle le
tandem parce qu'ils ont les mêmes
analyses et ça m'est égal je ne suis pas
là pour leur faire plaisir je peux les
combattre respectueusement mais les
combattre le temps de Mélenchon Le Pen
finalement nous explique que pour que la
France soit plus puissante on va
appauvrir sa monnaie on va appauvrir sa
population qui peut croire ça dans quel
pays ça a marché et je voudrais juste
rappeler que quand la dernière
dévaluation en France on nous parle
toujours de dévaluation compétitive
c'était pas un choix c'était imposé par
les marchés jamais un gouvernement n'a
choisi en tout cas depuis 40 ou 50 ans
on a choisi une d'évaluation on l'a subi
parce que nous étions trop faible dans
notre économie et que du coup les
marchés nous faisaient baisser la valeur
de la monnaie et nous faisait perdre de
l'argent très bien merci Deborah Michael
James de Public Sénat arrive maintenant
juste avant un détour par votre ville de
Drancy en Seine-Saint-Denis avec le
reportage de Samia dechir
il était moins connu du
grand à 47 ans Jean-Christophe Lagarde
dirige désormais le centre droit dont
l'image de consensus Moon ne lui
correspond pas vraiment dans le style
dans le dans la dynamique mais aussi
dans les décisions qu'il faut prendre
Jean-Christophe et quelqu'un qui ne
tombe pas dans la caricature qu'on fait
souvent des Centris c'est-à-dire que
c'est quelqu'un qui aime décider un
ambitieux offrant parler engagé très
jeune en politique par admiration pour
Raymond Barre s'est adorons si qu'il a
fait ses armes comme élu d'opposition
avant de prendre la ville au communistes
en 2001 elle s'est implanté à Drancy
depuis de nombreuses années depuis tout
petit
en travaillant sur le terrain boîte à
lettres par boîte aux lettres j'ai une
anecdote c'est que on tractait avec lui
dans les années 90 et les MDPH fait
attention il y a un chien méchant quand
tu vas mettre le tract il connaissait
toutes les rues et toutes les boîtes à
lettres désormais députés de
Seine-Saint-Denis il son troisième
mandat Drancy une forte implantation qui
l'aurait acquise selon ses opposants
grâce à un clientélisme à grande échelle
conseiller municipal d'opposition à sen
Shiban tient à nous en faire la
démonstration on est face à la au siège
du local de l'association Drancy
outre-mer
association qui dirigée par Monsieur
romain d'acheville qui lui-même est
adjoint au maire de Jean-Christophe
Lagarde donc en fait on a une
association qui est censée représenter
les personnes des DOM-TOM et
si vous êtes des DOM-TOM elle est
l'association référente et elle est
subventionnée par la Ville il tient à
nous emmener sur le site de la mosquée
un lieu de culte qu'il salue mais dont
il dénonce l'instrumentalisation pour
avoir cette cette mosquée il doit signer
une convention avec la mairie bien
évidemment on retrouve lors des
élections municipales l'association des
musulmans de Drancy appelant à voter
pour Jean -christophe Lagarde à Drancy
70% du budget de la mairie est consacré
à la masse salariale contre 50% avant
l'arrivée de Jean-Christophe Lagarde un
homme assurément ambitieux qui sait
s'entourer et ne cache désormais plus
ses ambitions présidentielles
alors Michael zafes nous a remis bonsoir
il y a des choses qui vous ont pas pu
dans le sujet je peux surtout corriger
déjà une énorme idée
la masse salariale de la ville de Drancy
c'est une des seules qui n'a quasiment
pas augmenté plus 0,5 % par an depuis 10
ans et donc les 70 % dont on parle
existé avant d'accord simplement il y a
deux choses qui se sont produites c'est
qu'on a créé une communauté
d'agglomération donc il y a une partie
des gens qui sont partis dans la
communauté d'agglomération qui ont
rétréci notre budget sa artificiellement
monter le taux donc c'est un mensonge
c'est normal quand on a des opposants
incompétents ils peuvent raconter ils
peuvent raconter n'importe quoi je peux
dire une deuxième blessure
la mosquée c'est un bail de 6 ans qui
est signé en l'occurrence avec des gens
que les musulmans se sont choisis c'est
pas moi qui l'ai choisi troisième chose
le responsable de conseiller outre-mer
qui mérite adjoint oui les mères
adjoints mais il était déjà responsable
de cette association avant les élections
municipales et parce que quelqu'un
responsable associatif devient élu je
dois le virer
c'est ça ce que ça veut dire ça veut
dire quoi le clientélisme c'est ridicule
tous les maires de France Pourquoi
profitent de la du dynamisme entre
guillemets de l'or responsable
associatif et parfois une partie d'entre
eux rentrent dans les conseils
municipaux il y a pas cadran-ci c'est
des mauvais procès débiles
quand on lit les portraits de vous ça
revient très très souvent ce mot
clientélisme le mot esprit communautaire
revient parce que j'aimerais savoir
c'est est-ce que vous avez tant
d'ennemis que ça chez vous à danser non
je surtout quelques gens qui n'ont pas
grand chose d'autre à dire je crois que
le monsieur qu'on voyait il a fait 10%
je crois aux dernières élections
municipales en tant que tête de vie
socialiste ah bon c'est intéressant
parce que moi je fais 75% c'est pas par
clientélisme c'est simplement que la
population elle écoute ce genre
d'énergumène et très franchement elles
s'en fiche et sur votre caractère ça va
peut-être dire aussi quelque chose on
dit souvent que vous êtes quelqu'un
d'assez d'assez fort au caractère tout
le monde doit marcher un peu la baguette
c'est vrai non non je pense que la force
de caractère c'est la capacité à
entraîner les autres pas les forcer et
je crois beaucoup à une chose c'est que
les conditions dans lesquelles vous êtes
élu qui permettent ou pas d'exercer vos
responsabilités et moi je cherche pas à
plaire à séduire ou à dénigrer je
cherche juste à convaincre et quand les
gens sont convaincus derrière ils vont
vous savez quand j'ai été lumière de
Drancy et bientôt 14 ans pendant un an
deux ans vous construisez une
administration vous trouvez des
économies qui vous permettent de
réaliser le projet vos projets et vous
préparer vos projets j'avais rien changé
à la vie rien parce que tout simplement
j'en avais pas encore eu le temps et la
population de Drancy me disait c'est
formidable ce que vous avez transformé
la ville simplement parce qu'il se
l'était réapproprié vous appelez ça du
clientélisme je les laisse non mais je
les laisse à leur médiocrité
nationale sur votre territoire sur
Drancy sur la Seine-Saint-Denis vous
avez un vrai problème sur l'éducation
nationale une éducation en faillite
Najat Vallaud-Belkacem la ministre de
l'Éducation a promis 500 postes pas
souvent les plus qualifiés qu'est-ce que
vous dites aujourd'hui à la ministre de
l'Éducation nationale on veut c'est 500
postes peu importe leur qualification
alors d'abord ils sont les bienvenus
parce qu'il y a quand même des soucis et
sérieux depuis l'arrivée du nouveau
gouvernement et même dans les deux
dernières années du
gouvernement Sarkozy
pardon mais je crois qu'il faut
simplement que la ministre elle
comprenne entre guillemets que la
question c'est pas seulement une
question de moyens c'est la
réorganisation complète de l'éducation
nationale sa capacité nationale chez
vous aujourd'hui oui sa capacité à
s'adapter et notamment chez nous pas que
chez nous mais chez nous
particulièrement parce que il faut
qu'elle s'adapte à des spécificités je
vais vous en prendre une quand vous
concentrez toute la misère sociale ou
tous les nouveaux arrivants sur notre
territoire vous a rendez la mission de
l'école beaucoup plus difficile voire
impossible j'ai une école maternelle
dans ma ville ou près des deux tiers des
élèves sont des élèves qui ne parlent
pas français ce sont des gens qui
arrivent du subcontinent indien depuis
peu de temps moi je mets le paquet
j'offre gratuitement à tous les parents
on va appeler ça du clientélisme
la possibilité d'apprendre à lire et à
écrire notamment aux mamans parce que
l'échange entre parents et enseignant
comment il se fait quand les parents ne
parlent pas français mais l'éducation
nationale elle prend des gamins de trois
ans quatre 25 ans à l'école maternelle
elle ne leur apprend pas le français et
elle attend qu'ils aient six ans pour
qu'il y ait un enseignant qui cherche à
leur apprendre le français c'est une
folie quelle image les parents de
l'école quelle image ses enfants qui
jouent entre dans la cour à part ont de
l'école voilà ce que Madame
Vallaud-Belkacem devrait venir regarder
pardon pas que des voyages financiers
une autre méthode
ne veulent pas être nommés par exemple
en Seine-Saint-Denis j'imagine également
ils veulent pas rester chez vous pas les
enseignants mais une partie d'entre eux
et surtout en général ils ne choisissent
pas de venir là parce qu'on prend les
plus jeunes et pas toujours les mieux
formés ou ceux qui ont eu déjà une
certaine expérience et oui il y a besoin
de revaloriser mais c'est pas quand
c'est le samedi dans les quartiers
populaires il y a besoin de revalides de
le revaloriser les carrières et les
salaires de ceux qui viennent s'y
installer on peut faciliter l'accession
à la propriété on peut faire beaucoup de
choses ça n'est pas fait c'est souvent
dit sur les plateaux de télé ça n'est
pas fait mais il faut être pas capable
de prendre en compte la spécificité de
telle ou tel secteur tel ou tel quartier
parce que vous savez ce qu'on répond à
la directrice d'école de cette de cette
école dont je vous parle de l'école
maternelle dont je vous parle je vais
pas cité son nom mais on lui dit mais
madame puisqu'ils sont en maternelle il
baigne dans un bain linguistique
francophone bah non bah non et c'est pas
parce qu'il y a certains postes de plus
que ça va arriver le problème c'est
parce qu'on va casser un code bête de
l'éducation nationale qui dit qu'on
attend d'être au CP pour apprendre le
français alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait à la
maternelle
si vous avez vu ce rapport qui préconise
de supprimer les notes à l'école
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez fantastique
je trouve que c'est fantastique en
réalité nous sortons évidemment nous
nous sortons nous sortons 180000
personnes jeunes chaque année du système
scolaire sans savoir lire et écrire et
pas depuis le gouvernement depuis 20 ou
25 ans et là le gouvernement socialiste
arrive de révolution très importante
première révolution on réforme des temps
scolaires sauf que on touche pas au
week-end pour pas gêner on touche pas
aux vacances pour pas gêner les
enseignants et industrie du tourisme et
en réalité on a touché à trois quarts
d'heure par jour les enfants sont là
aussi longtemps ça coûte cher ils sont
aussi fatigués c'est un échec vous
pensez que les ateliers
vous pensez que les vous pensez que les
ateliers pompons macramé ou dessin ça
permet à des gamins qui ont besoin de
lire écrire et compter correctement de
progresser je pense que c'est de la
démocratie
et la deuxième grande réforme
l'évaluation des élèves la deuxième
grande réforme l'évaluation des élèves
c'est fantastique avant on avait les
notes entre 0 et 10 ou entre 0 et 20 et
maintenant on va avoir des couleurs un
petit peu de rouge petit peu de vert un
petit peu de jaune
qu'est-ce que c'est carton rouge carton
rouge parce que franchement qu'est-ce
que ça change c'est se moquer du monde
vous êtes vous étiez sans doute un élève
brillant et vous êtes arrivé peut-être
de temps en temps d'avoir de mauvaises
notes
vraiment ça vous a effondré au point moi
je pense au contraire que le mérite
c'est le principe premier de la
République et que se faire évaluer c'est
la façon de pouvoir regarder son mérite
et il y a même une chose c'est qu'il
faut pas regarder là où elle pourrait
non pas avoir raison parce que c'est pas
du tout son système mais on pourrait
changer quelque chose ce qui compte à la
limite c'est moins la note que la
progression c'est de voir la progression
que les faits il peut démarrer très mal
et il peut progresser à Drancy depuis 12
ans on met le paquet pour que tous les
élèves de CP ça s'appelle l'opération
coup de pouce tous les élèves de CP par
groupe de 5 lundi mardi jeudi vendredi
pendant une heure et demie il faisait
une pédagogie adaptée inventée par des
inspecteurs généraux de l'éducation
nationale ça a 82 ou 88% selon les
années de bons résultats ça en fait des
bons lecteurs des bonscripteurs et je
viens de commencer cette année et je
viens de commencer je termine juste
là-dessus et je viens de commencer cette
année à le faire en CM1 ça coûte 1000
euros par an et par gosse mais il vaut
mieux mettre 1000 euros par an et par
gosse et rattraper ceux qui partaient
vers l'échec scolaire ça évite de les
avoir dans l'assistance sociale pendant
des décennies après sur le mariage pour
tous
d'être l'un des seuls parlementaires à
pouvoir voter droit de centre droit pour
ce mariage pour tous Nicolas Sarkozy l'a
dit la baugera s'il revient au pouvoir
en 2017 ce mot brogation vous le
reprenez pour vous aussi en tout cas
pour votre famille centriste d'abord
dans notre famille politique sur les
sujets de société il y a liberté de vote
de liberté de conscience parce que ce
sont des sujets qui touchent à l'intime
c'est la règle c'est ma conviction ma
conviction personnelle c'est qu'il n'y
avait pas de raison pour
nier une égalité en droit en fonction de
l'orientation sexuelle pour le mariage
et pour l'adoption des enfants je suis
résolument hostile et à la PMA et à la
GPA pour création médicalement
en revanche entendre aujourd'hui des
responsables de l'opposition dire qu'ils
vont revenir sur Nicolas Sarkozy comme
d'autres dire qu'ils vont revenir sur le
mariage pour tous je pense que c'est un
mensonge ça ne se fera pas je me
souviens que il y a quelques il y a
quelques jours nous célébrions les 40
ans de la loi veille qui a donné le
droit aux femmes d'aborder lorsque elle
ne surtout pas supporter une grossesse
c'est pas un moyen de contraception
c'était un traumatisme on entendait la
même droite ou en tout cas leurs aînés
expliquer on reviendra sur l'avortement
on va effacer tout ça ils ne l'ont pas
fait il devait annuler les 35 heures ils
ne l'ont pas fait et vous savez pourquoi
ils le font pas d'abord parce que
d'abord parce que ça n'est pas
constitutionnel deuxièmement parce qu'on
ne joue pas avec la vie des gens et
qu'on ne peut pas avoir demain les
mariés d'avant la loi Taubira les mariés
de pendant la loi temira et les mariés
de l'après loat Taubira et que la
troisième raison
finalement à chaque fois c'est pour
faire plaisir un petit groupe muscul
quand je regarde le résultat de l'UMP ça
fait combien de fois effectivement le
candidat anti mariage pour tous monsieur
Mariton au sein de l'UMP 6%. peut-être
que la réponse est donnée là voilà on ne
reviendra pas sur cette loi et
franchement le français je crois qu'ils
ont d'autres priorités ils aimeraient
avoir du boulot plutôt que des lois sur
le mariage pour tous d'ailleurs petite
question
Napoléon venait au pouvoir pour Manuel
Valls son modèle c'est Clémenceau
Napoléon
vous avez fait une thèse alors pour le
compte non pas une thèse mais j'en ai
j'en ai plusieurs il y a riche le lieu
parce que c'est le sens de l'état réel
Napoléon parce que c'est un moment donné
la réorganisation et le redressement et
la modernisation de la France Clémenceau
par la capacité de résistance des
morceaux
et Charles de Gaulle pour des raisons
évidentes et similaires merci Jean
Christophe Lagarde d'avoir été avec nous
merci Michael bonsoir à tous à très vite